all right Molina yes Elena where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I'm originally from the San Fernando
Valley
um grew up in that area
tell me about your family growing up
uh about my family yeah your mom and dad
yeah
um you know it's not always what it
seems though like I would say like I
feel like uh sometimes you can have a
white picket fence and a nice pretty
house but you don't know what's really
inside you know what lurks deep into
those crevices or beneath the surface
it was just very dysfunctional like a
lot of abuse and
um you know I just tried to find an
escape so I've always been kind of an
Escapist like my propensity is always
like when things get crazy or hard to
just run away like you know try to like
get my mind off stuff what was going on
with your parents yeah well like I don't
know what was going on between their
marriage it's not like we ever spoke
about anything in our family about
anything of like conflict or what was
going on in the home it was always very
uh
just go go with the flow in a sense
almost like I don't know there was just
a lot of ups and downs maybe financially
um regardless though like I suffered a
lot of uh
physical abuse
sexual abuse
a lot of just different types of
emotional abuse as well so I had always
wanted to think of like not growing up
dysfunctional but like you know it's
hard when your home life is very
tumultuous I guess you know
um so I do whatever I knew best which
was at that time like I thought I was
like gonna wait till I got to 18 years
old so I can leave that house you know
and never come back
um and it didn't turn out that way you
know when it turned out to be 18 I go
[__] you know like I got to realize how
to be an adult
um and within all of that Spear of
everything it just it collapsed because
it's not something stable you know like
when you're mentally not there
like you're you're occupied with other
things or like figuring out your home
situation or where you're going to live
you know
um and I used to just hang out with a
lot of different people get drunk or
like you know
um
I started drinking a lot actually that
was like kind of where it started um I
smoked weed and stuff
um you know the probably the hardest
thing I did was cocaine and um maybe
that was like where it kind of led to
other things too like I was like okay
cool I'll try some pills here and there
you know nothing ever that like stuck
though and then
I just started kind of
doing better and then going back into
that whole of addiction
um you know and I also grew up with a an
alcoholic father
um so it was strange to see that also as
like a normal thing like that's the way
to cope with things you know you just
like
move on you don't really deal with it
so I kind of try to like educate myself
a little bit more to have some tools
with knowing how I could kind of just in
this Essence unfuck myself you know I
figured if I learned this Behavior I can
unlearn it so I focused on that because
I think you know I would never have
wanted to have somebody in that kind of
environment I started kind of realizing
things when I started dating people
and um probably like at that point where
I was 19 years old I I kind of started
dating somebody who was a drug dealer
um and
it started to make me realize that the
kind of person that I was once that
relationship ended
and I started kind of viewing myself as
more of a person that needed to change
because I was so angry and I used to be
just very
careless you know I used to do whatever
at the whatever emotion I was led by my
emotions basically you know instead of
just thinking about things first and not
uh you know letting my anger get to me
because it was always an issue with me
with my anger and I don't know if it's
sort of like some deep stem kind of
weird issue or whatever I don't know
that's why I get high sometimes I'm just
like I don't want to deal with this [__]
like you know I just kind of like Get
Away
um but it just kind of went bad after
that domino effect you know snowfalled
into worse and that's just how that goes
sometimes like when you don't realize
that you're a person that suffers from
addiction
um you cannot drink the same way that
everyone else does or that may not
suffer from addiction like the you know
the predisposition that you might have
might lead you to making uh worse
decisions in your life because you not
you're not able to uh take substances
the same way as other people might be
right like maybe somebody might be able
to drink and stop but like when I used
to get drunk or drink I couldn't stop
like I would just you know there's some
alcoholics they drink every day others
they drink on the weekend and they
Splurge right
um they're still alcoholics nonetheless
so that was kind of like that we can
Splurge your kind of thing like I would
start and I didn't want to stop and then
I would just get belligerent and out of
hand in hostile and
um I realized that there was something
that I needed to work on
um
yeah how old are you now I'm 32 years
old three two do you have children no I
have no children no kids no
I hadn't miraculously never had children
but you know
um almost had a little scare and like
that kind of affected me too because it
was something that like a grieving
process you know
um
I wouldn't I don't regret anything
though you know because I realized that
the the partner that I was with and I we
made the right choice and not uh
choosing to move forward with that
because it was better for our lives at
that point you know
um at least for myself I speak you know
that that was I don't I don't regret it
you know like it is what it is it was my
choice at the time I was young
um
you know but
you know it's just weird it's a weird
thing to deal with sometimes like
grieving
um
but
yeah I don't know so maybe sometimes
like I'm not able to have the tools to
cope with those emotions so I turned to
drugs usually as my escapism how long
you've been on the streets uh for
now it's been about
um
maybe like three years I'm gonna say
um I had been doing well here and there
and then I started dating a heroin
addict
um I didn't know that he was a heroin
addict you know I knew something was up
I'm a drug user so I figured he was on
drugs but never heroin
I had never even been around it like
that and um I kind of started dabbling
with that person
um you know and just got stuck a little
bit on that and it was kind of scary
because I was in a sense high
functioning but then not because heroin
always takes everything away from you
and the opiate does like that's how it
starts starts to take everything out of
your life like you know you have a car
you have a job well when you start
dating heroin not any longer you know
just everything becomes about that
becomes about heroin and obtaining it
because you're physically dependent on
it what are you using now
um right now I'm just on crystal meth
like I've just been
um literally clean after five years of
fentanyl use
[Music]
um
I graduated like I say ago
um back when heroin was a thing because
fentanyl was new on the scene and um
it's so crazy to me because I was kind
of around for like that Heyday of like
what fentanyl now is today
um because it's pretty it's crazy to me
in a sense really because people didn't
do it the way they are doing it right
now and it was like kind of kind of a
little more I don't know
it's it's very uh a known thing almost
and heroin wasn't even you know so it's
kind of strange to me because there was
a lot of heroin addicts though
and there still is kind of still here
and there scattered throughout you know
people didn't really say graduate to
fentanyl because they knew that it was
worse but that's why some Phantom I'm
sorry some heroin addicts went to
fentanyl use because it would get you
messed up quicker faster with less
so even though it was more expensive
though so it's like you already have a
problem obtaining your your habit for
heroin like fentanyl is way worse you
know so that was always my scare but
eventually I graduated to it too
where do you stay currently
uh currently right now I'm homeless I
literally just got out of County jail
and I'm starting at square one I'm
trying to just become a little bit more
independent stabilize myself you know
like I feel like that's that's not a
fear that I should have like the fact
that like I don't know where to start or
do this or that like it should you know
it should eventually at this point in my
time in life like I think it's something
that's probably natural of my age to try
to you know try to do it on my own you
know like I'm not a I don't know how do
you typically support yourself when
you're uh specifically in the streets
I'm not gonna lie like I'm I'm kind of a
criminal like
um I commit crimes like I as I steal I
boost what is called boosting
um so like I'll go to stores and I'll
steal high-end merchandise and um sell
it in the streets for money in return
you know that's what I used to do for
drugs at least and it was always like a
quick thing you know
um
there's like a whole Black Market
that we participate in and everyone
knows it you know and so is just about
our fix but like I kind of got more into
like knowing that my habit was something
serious so I wanted more of it at the
same time so I tried to like make my
money go longer you know like just
different things and it just goes into a
whole Vice of the whole lifestyle of it
all and
um I think I was addicted to that too
more than anything the lifestyle of it
I don't I don't know like fast money I
guess um
have you entertained men entertainment
as an attractive female you you know an
option all the time it's funny because
that's always yes that's always I'm
always being propositioned with that um
in this in the start of things
um not necessarily like that but in a
sense because I I remember I ran into
somebody at one point when I was trying
to score and um he was really cool like
we were friends we were hanging out and
stuff and like he was like yeah I got
you whatever you know like I had I had
money I wasn't a thing about that but we
started kind of networking and you know
it kind of just kind of made sense for
us with the money in the in the sense of
like I did do uh some pleasure favors
for some men in return but never like
intercourse it was always like you know
like I'm a very creative person in that
process so I feel like when it comes to
servicing or you know customer service I
guess in a sense like I'll deliver like
A1 service honestly like I'm all about
like making the person happy like and
that's what I feel like at the end of
the day like it that man receives
pleasure like that like I'm all for it
because he's happy now you know and
we're both happy it's a it's a it's a
negotiation that goes on you know and I
like that like it's it's cool when
you're able to negotiate that so that
was a cool thing too about that friend
was like because I guess you could call
that like pimping and hoeing or
something you know I learned that when I
first went to to County L.A County
Linwood
um back then it was different 10 years
ago and I just returned now 10 years
later from there like the longest thing
I did and um I mean I learned that like
hoeing and like that stuff like it's a
real thing like seriously like it was
like these girls are telling me like
their their daddies are gonna come pick
them up in the limousine with a blunt
rolled up and a brand new outfit and I'm
just like oh that's crazy that's cool
though you know like it's a trip to me
because I would think like okay you go
and you do all this work though and you
give your money to your pimp though like
how does it work you know like to me it
was just it doesn't make sense though
like how are you profiting from it like
where is your benefit right and I go
okay I understand that there's certain
roles though you know and that's the
thing and I just don't know that some
people might adhere to those same roles
that's a thing so that was kind of
different between my interaction with
that friend was that like he wasn't like
that he was more like listen I'm gonna
negotiate my part and you negotiate your
part and I liked that because I was like
cool that leaves me in charge of my
stuff you know like I got that like you
know so it worked out it worked out well
it worked out it was something quick and
fast like it wasn't anything permanent
you know
um it became a problem with jealousy too
within his own uh group of friends so
that was kind of the main concern thing
like the main thing was that it was like
we were starting to get a lot of money
really quick and I was like cool because
I like to make money fast you know like
I'm smart at that in a sense because I
was like okay like they were older men
you know and I liked that in a sense
because it's different it's a different
kind of like a Vibe like they enter they
I feel like they're more appreciative of
certain things right like if I'm gonna
do like a massage let's say you know
like and it's just as well as
pleasurable as maybe if you would have
had intercourse but maybe you want to
see me again after that you know what I
mean because maybe you enjoyed that
interaction and it was like that like he
he afterwards because I got into a
little bit of a tiff with some of the
girls that got jealous because they were
doing it differently with them and it
was like well you know he and he had his
his friends so it was a couple of guys
with a couple of girls and um it was
just funny how that happened and um it
was a trip man it was a real trip it was
a real real entertaining not
entertaining but like it was eye-opening
here just it was a weird experience in a
sense like a normal person wouldn't
experience what I experienced in that
like
period of time
and um you think you're seeing things
that are making you jaded
now yeah no never that like I feel like
my mental state has always been
something that I had as a stronghold
like I mean you know that's why right
now at least I got sober because I just
was like like I don't want to be losing
my mind you know I don't want to be like
out here really like schizophrenic or
something like that because that's a
real propensity that some people have
with crystal meth
um you know so obviously deprived they
get well and not just that though but
like there's scientific evidence that
proves that some people might have a
predisposition for like mental health
illness right and let's say your whole
life you go without having it triggered
you're fine you're normal the moment you
smoke crystal meth though it Triggers on
schizophrenia paranoia other delusional
issues you know like all the time yes
and so I mean that's kind of been my
stronghold that I've never been addicted
to Crystal Meth like that like I can
stop use it and just like I like it
because listen when I'm on the streets
sometimes you don't have anywhere to
stay and so I want to stay awake and I
want to stay alert I don't want to be in
and it helps me do that like it helps me
stay at least a little bit more safe how
many days have you stayed awake well at
the maximum it seemed that sleep
deprivation is a real thing and people
don't understand that part
um and I get it though it's a real bad
thing because I had been at one point
like the worst time it was two weeks
where I was sleep deprived and I was
going two weeks hard like it was bad it
was on a med binge and also too I was
withdrawing from Fentanyl and I was
trying to get clean you know and I got
clean like that though I got cleaning
the streets cold turkey so crystal meth
helped you get off of fentanyl in a
sense I'm gonna say yes because it
helped me with post-acute withdrawal
syndromes which are a real thing like
people may not be prepared for that part
but like positive they call it pause for
short it's a real thing with opiate
addicts like you know and map programs
help too like I've had friends who got
clean like that so that kind of
encouraged me like I had moments where I
kind of broke down and I was just like I
miss my life being sober clean almost in
a way but like it's weird because
they'll say like fentanyl or opiate
addicts unless they really want to quit
they'll quit kind of thing you know and
this time around it's weird because I
didn't want to you're saying you're
saying until they really want to quit
correct like if they don't really want
to stop doing it they're not going to
kind of thing okay and it's not like
they say like they'll say I really want
to but I I can't they don't really want
to that's the thing and um when you make
that maximum that you really do want to
because of some reason or something that
is in you that you want to not do that
you'll not do it
and I had those moments but I never
actually went through with it like I was
like I didn't have the support system
and now recently like it was like I was
forced in a sense to do it but I'm glad
I kind of was because it helped me
really kind of take more accountability
too and like realize that like okay like
I really need a shape up like this has
been five years of my life that I wasted
just smoking fentanyl everyday scoring
every moment like like when I move from
the moment that I woke up that I wake up
I wake up and I put my clothes on and I
gotta go to go make money to make my
fentanyl habit go you know and that's
all a fentanyl addict thinks about is
about scoring and making money to have
their their stash
and uh I was tired of living like that
like I really was like this is
exhausting me now like at one point it
wasn't it was really like I was kind of
coasting really really uh
in a way it was comfortable because I
didn't have to worry really I was I was
doing really well I could support my
habit I had a roof over my head in a
sense like you know because I was in
hotel rooms and stuff
um comfortable
and didn't miss a meal you know excuse
me
but um
after that though it ended up not being
well like it ended up being like we're
now I'm I'm
over here doing smaller smaller stashes
and stuff and like it's just not working
out like this isn't it's not doing
anything good for me you know
so is being a crystal meth addict more
manageable than a fentanyl you know it
seems like it's a little bit more
socially acceptable as a norm and
certain Social Circles like
um I'm not gonna lie like I like to
party sometimes I like I'm a very
sexually open person too like I don't
think there should be anything taboo
about sexuality I think it's a very cool
topic that you know why wouldn't we be
talking about that as an adult I'm sorry
me personally though I might my mind is
a little more sexually geared maybe
sometimes
um not to say that I'm promiscuous or
anything like that it's just I enjoy sex
right
um but um and I like partying when I
have sex sometimes and crystal meth is
kind of a sex drug
um so in a sense like I like doing it
like that and I'll say I'll be honest
like some people smoke it some people
shoot it some people snort it and some
people also ingest it right
um and they also anally ingested too you
know and that's really like listen I
tried that one time and it freaked me
the [__] out because they got me too
high and I go dude no what the hell like
I almost like called the paramedics
because like I was freaking out I was
like oh my gosh I've never been so high
in my life off crystal meth like turkey
turkey baster right yes something like
that you know what the turkey baster is
kind of oh my gosh you just remind me of
some crazy stories right now like with
me and my ex-boyfriend with turkey
basting because like I remember when I
used to do heroin and I was like I don't
know we were trying to like get me off
fentanyl so he's trying to get me on
heroin and we'd like put that in like a
syringe with the needle cut off and then
he'd put that up my anal my ass you know
I'd be laughing because it was like some
it's sort of fun for him to do that [__]
you know and I would be laughing like
you know this is funny it's crazy
because people do that in jail with the
heroin they call it Carlito
they snort it though and um I just was
like I wanted to delivery quicker faster
whatever and it was a different kind of
High
um even with the crystal meth like that
it's a different high and though I'll be
honest with what I really enjoy is
shooting crystal meth and having sex
because it's just a whole different
experience like your body is literally
like it's just it feels like the mo the
first time I ever did it I felt like I
was literally
ejaculating in my pants like I felt like
that you know and I was just like what
the [__] like this is crazy like I like
it I enjoy it and like you know it makes
you it makes you excited
um sexually aroused uh so you know and I
I like to have a good time you know what
can I say sex is fun to me like I like
to have different kinds of uh elements
added to it you know I don't know I'm
weird I now enjoy sex if you're not
using crystal meth of course you know
like that's not like a necessity like it
has to be there like no
um I just sometimes like if if the
moment arises kind of thing and it's
like kind of it's an opportunity or
whatever I'm not gonna say no like I
enjoy it you know so I'll be like yeah
cool I like that but it's not something
I depend on I think that's the real
reason that people are interested you
know start using crystal meth no I don't
think so I don't really know honestly I
think it affects people differently
um because like I said when I smoke I
could smoke forever and ever and all
I'll do is like start cleaning like I'm
I'm a tweaker that cleans and like some
people get annoyed with that but that's
just what I do I like to I don't know so
then I like doing it because I can get
more productive at certain things so and
that's kind of a bad propensity too
because
people do that academically too and they
get addicted to Adderall they get
addicted to speed and cocaine and it's a
big problem
um functioning addicts you know and
that's kind of the thing with my my
addiction is like I could become a
functioning addict and it scares me
because like that's what I realized when
I had my heroin opiate addiction was
like I didn't stop because I didn't want
to I could stop whenever I wanted to and
I had moments where like I'd quit and I
wouldn't use for like two three weeks
two weeks one week off whatever and like
I'd still go back to it though
and it was just like okay I can quit
whenever I want I don't want to quit
though so then I never quit
and um you know I just had to catch
myself
and say like you know this is this is
not cool no more like you know what's
freaked me out even more was like with
fentanyl you doze off
you don't even know where you're at and
you're so unconscious that like you
wouldn't even feel if somebody was
touching you or stealing your stuff
and you think like anything would wake
you up not when you're high on fentanyl
not when you've gotten to your high
which like I always say like you can't
get much higher than that but something
they'll still they're hitting in they're
falling asleep and you're wasting your
dope I'm sorry that's like you're
wasting your dope
um you can't get higher and you know
um some people think that they're
chasing that high the first time I don't
think that's true I think it's just that
like at least for me it wasn't that it
was that I enjoyed it I liked it I liked
opiates I liked feeling numb I liked you
know it it completely Cuts you off a
feeling like if you have all these like
emotions sometimes like you think like
oh I feel bad about this or I'm mad
about this you smoke some fentanyl all
that [__] goes away Crystal Method
doesn't happen no I think crystal meth
might amplify sometimes and it amplifies
yourself maybe to being more emotional
or angry
and um that's kind of where I kind of
draw that line because I don't want it
to affect me like that you know that's
why I do it in like short little burst
or you know like to me it's not it's not
a problem
I can do it and stop
but you know I I just don't see it as
being a negative in my life right now
other than like sometimes it affects my
speech or like
you know you don't feel like you're
wasting you're spinning your wheels down
here living this life
um well you know what it's like you know
kind of in a sense I I understand what
you're saying you're in your early 30s
eventually yeah yeah totally I get you
yeah you know totally right that's why
like right now I'm trying to you know
for me it's a big step that I got I'm
four months sober now off of fentanyl
off of being fentanyl attic for five
years consecutively and so um that was
definitely probably five years out of
your life that was wasted completely
completely utterly you know just
completely and utterly but you know
covet hit
um people were out of work anyways
people were just lounging and not doing
stuff regardless you know kind of in a
sense like people just started not to
give a [__] away I think you know and
so I didn't give a [__] either and I was
on fentanyl like my feelings are
completely desensitized to the utmost
degree
like you don't care about anything or
anyone it's a [__] up relationship
um
and you know it just was like yeah okay
I had my run with it and it didn't take
till maybe losing somebody very
important to me that always wanted to
say that like you know we should have
been clean and like be you know sober
and want the best for one another and
like that kind of made me wake up was
like that like I no longer had this
person in my life that
um was a support system and for in a
sense of an honor or something like that
you know like that they knew that I
wasn't just a waste you know like that I
was wasting my talents or I was wasting
my like my brain in a way you know like
I literally have like three years to
finish school to like pursue my
professional like life you know and uh
so I I don't know like I I'm an Escapist
though through and through I have to
admit who I am you know and I'm in that
process right now of like being able to
just like take accountability and grow
from there
so yeah crystal meth has helped me
though like in a sense it really has
it's helped me keep myself off of doing
opiates you know like when I feel like
the need to have that anxiety of like I
smell it it triggers me and I want to do
it I just smoke a little bit of crystal
meth to get the edge off or I'll smoke
some weed weed helps too I think
marijuana is a really good resource
um but it kind of gets me a little goofy
so I don't like to really do that one
too much because it's crazy that I think
sometimes we books do it more than
fentanyl or like or then it makes you
more you know like just it's crazy like
concentrates are just like it's a weird
thing I always used to think that and
then I had stopped smoking it when I did
opiates but
um that's probably where I [__] up
I've interviewed probably more than a
handful of people who have said crystal
meth has really helped them you know
what and um I honestly didn't believe it
at first but I had when I was using
fentanyl
um I had other crystal meth addicts who
would tell me that like that they said
you know I have a friend who got clean
off a fentanyl with crystal meth well
tons of crack addicts have gotten off of
crack with crystal meth oh I didn't know
that tons yeah because I'm not gonna
live partied with that too you know like
they're similar drugs and I think they
probably just you know exactly
I've only done them in sexual um uh
interactions you know so yeah I
understand that you know like it's it's
just bizarre because I can understand
too where like that addiction goes real
bad
um can you compare sex without drugs to
sex with crystal meth for you
sex without drugs and sex with crystal
meth
um it's the same thing in a way you know
because if I'm not using a party favor
I'm using some kind of like accessory
like you know like I'm like I want
lingerie like I want Boudoir feelings
you know like and it's just weirdo like
that like I want to Vibe when I'm doing
sex like I want it to be a whole
experience like you know like literally
involve all of your senses in a sense
you know like um and it's exploration
for me you know and it's better to take
it slow that's what people don't get
they jump into just you know [__]
screwing whatever you know and I get it
cool dude you know like that's awesome
too but like it's better kind of I feel
I'm a weirdo like I'm like I want to
like go slow and I want to like you know
like they always say like I was the kind
of kind of uh bothers me or whatever but
they like some guys would be like oh I
like to see my fish squirm in a sense
it's kind of like the same idea like you
know you take it real slow and like want
to see kind of the reaction or like how
like I don't know like when you like
somebody or not like just the process of
it is different for me like slowly deal
of it I've talked with a lot of guys who
use crystal methane yeah or they have
experimented with it yeah and they say
it just it's the difference between like
for a guy there yeah they have their
orgasm they're done yeah but on crystal
meth they can't ever yeah it's crazy yes
that's crazy it's so crazy because they
become slapstick happy I say you know
because and then I always think they're
like but what is it though like I don't
know like to me it's just
I'm into edging which is like a whole
thing of like holding your orgasm you
know and like or not letting the other
person orgasm like right before they're
gonna orgasm you just don't let them
orgasm kind of thing you know just like
it's a weird thing right but like it
kind of makes your endurance go bigger
and better like I don't know and
sometimes when people do drugs like they
lose that sensitivity to and it affects
their sex drive I think for sure and
like their performance and then you know
like it just becomes just like another
like to me I was like I was thinking
like this is weird for me because guys
are different I think on crystal methods
and it's weird because they get very
very very sexually aroused
to like they just have certain other
predilections I think that there might
be they're high they're open to you get
me like you know so I'm just like you
know okay maybe this guy starts doing a
glory hole I don't know you know it just
open anything goes anything goes pretty
much you know no secret on the street I
think is there's there's plenty of
straight guys that are no longer
straight thank you
that you addressed that Pro that that's
not a problem but I mean I mean I listen
I wouldn't want you know that's purely
because of crystal meth it's crazy
though because I don't know if that's
true I think maybe that's just a a
reason for them to say that like as an
excuse almost because they don't accept
themselves really I swear I swear to you
and it's it's a depression it's
repressed sexuality you know and it's
crazy to me because I go like well you
know thank God that the crystal meth
opened you up though you get me like you
know hey you know because Life's too
short to not be having the type of sex
you want and enjoying your life the way
you want to do it like you know and sex
is one of those free things like are you
kidding me like and hey you should be
having the kind of sex you want to have
orgasm man like you know like and hey
it's it just feels good dude you know
like it makes you a happy person that's
why I always say men are living their
best life man honestly because like they
keep it simple they are not and you know
what it's it's not it's not to say that
they're like stupid or anything like
because simple things can be complex
very complex but they don't make it
complicated you know in a sense they
they have complications and they're very
they're very complex as a speech she's
you know or like the responsibility or
their roses are male
um and I always say look it has anything
to do with sexuality because I have been
treated better by gay men than straight
men okay like there have been more of
gentlemen chivalrous I mean some of my
best friends I'm a LGBT member myself
I'm bisexual so um I'm openly bisexual
though and I'm always like the B is the
hardest one to be like it really is
because especially for men I get it too
like you know being openly bisexual male
it's even difficult even more difficult
even for me like as a female like I'll
meet males who they're like I don't like
that I don't like that you like women
like I'm going like what the [__] like
so then I can't even express my
sexuality if I wanted to I'll tell you
like one of my really good relationships
that I had was the ability to be able to
let go of possessiveness and experience
like having a threesome like you know
being open sexually and
um it was cool for me because I was like
wow this is a really good experience for
me like I was able to actually express
my sexuality or explore it healthy in a
really relationship and open
communication and like we had a lot of
fun like we would be like it was like we
were double teaming girls and stuff you
know like it was funny to us like and we
like that [__] you know like it was
weird we were just weird it was like we
like enjoy sex in a different kind of a
way
um but you know
um
and that was a crystal meth addict you
know
um you know so there's different things
there you know like that happen and I
just think that it's weird though that
sometimes men don't want to talk about
how like they might be bisexual or they
might be uh just gay you know like I
mean you're either gay or you're
bisexual right I mean I don't know I I
don't know you know
um I would say too like it's crazy
because they go I don't know I'm just
thinking like how like certain things
are like perfect matches in a sense for
like a bisexual male or like you know
and people don't talk about that stuff
though like they don't want to be like
open about the sexuality you're like
open to different type of uh individuals
and how they uh interact sexually
and um why not I mean who the [__] cares
it's just you and your printer anyways
or that you and that person or whoever
it is how many other people like you
know because some people enjoy having uh
multiple people and having an orgy you
know like I mean hey to each their own
different Stokes for different folks and
there's nothing wrong with that though I
don't understand why there's such a
shame or like a an embarrass like I
don't know like I think it's unfortunate
really a lot of people are very uptight
about sex yes like lip tight lift or
like you know like hottie or like like
very very
you know oh no no very taboo
and I always call that like the Scarlet
lettering of sexuality because it's
embedded and she's like oh let's she's
she's a red letter that's a red letter
you know like Shame Shame Shame you're
an adulterer you know like I mean
perhaps it was just an open relationship
though if they would have been uh
idealistic to that like or more uh you
know open to that idea of like hey maybe
we just might be into an open
relationship or like we're pluralistic
kind of people like you know I think law
of religion and sex are all tightly
connected and it's hard to
you know I don't want to I don't I think
it's not so much religion as it it might
be I don't know how you want it yeah I
understand what you're saying for sure
religious yes no I wasn't saying not
really ingrained in our culture yes in
American culture though American you
know North America too yeah some no you
know what I'm I'm gonna tell you
something not really because you know
what I've been to Latin America and
different Latin American countries
Nicaragua for sure like they have a lot
of gay people and that's why a lot more
Nicaraguan communities are in Miami or
like in San Francisco Bay area and I go
these guys are loving it and I like it I
love it because they're openly able to
express themselves like I was thinking
about that go San Francisco they have a
BDSM parade okay like they got people
naked in the street like in like
shackles and like you know what I mean
like in like a hogtied and like all
kinds of other crazy stuff like
um you know exhibitionists who want to
be like spanked or whipped publicly
things like that where it's like cool
dude like that's awesome you can express
your sexuality openly and freely and be
afraid and like I mean are ashamed I'm
not gonna say afraid but it's more like
I you know even afraid because I always
tell like I go if I had a gay best
friend and he was dating somebody who
was classy I would slap him be like you
deserve better love because that's you
know I understand maybe there's there's
something more
um
psychologically going on there but that
person doesn't have the the boss to live
their life and it's like we've already
had gay activists from the 60s like the
HIV crisis like are we're in 2023 and
we're still experiencing the same thing
of like does like 1930s 1940s kind of
housewives with like men who actually
are are not interested in being with a
woman but like actually are gay but they
do it for the duty of like I have to
have a family for my family and I can't
be gay you know like that's crazy to me
like I don't understand it and that's
why I say like more power to those
people because they don't get they're
too afraid to live their lives and it's
like it's not an easy life to live you
know because those people have been
maybe um shunned from their own families
um they've been thrown out they've been
treated badly you know and so that's why
we have gay rights and activists who try
to promote more openness and more uh
acceptance
and that's where I say it's acceptance
really embedded in acceptance of like
this is who I am cool I don't why should
anyone care I say who gives a [__] who
you're [__] other than somebody who
wants to [__] you it's no one else's
business you know that part I swear to
God if someone's really that interested
in your sexual life it's because they
want to be included in your sexual life
you know I agree
um so you know and and maybe that makes
some people feel angry it triggers them
I think maybe like and and that's not
cool too because it's like you know
that's an ugly thing to me you know but
that's to me somebody maybe who's been
traumatized or something like that about
it or like shamed about it like you know
like growing up also too like I remember
like my mother would always tell me like
that I was like a lesbian or something
like that like she would she'd make it
sound like a bad thing like oh like
don't ever like like just shaming it
shaming you you know so like I couldn't
be like I'm bisexual but then I don't
give a [__] if she knows if I'm bisexual
or not she's not in my [__] sex life
like who gives a [__] you know and at
the end of the day I'm still openly
[__] bisexual I like women but I like
men more you know um
uses women are kind of um
I hang out more with men so I'm a kind
of more minded like a man
um but maybe that's why I don't get
along with women so well because they
get like very jealous or like Petty and
just like I go like I don't I don't
really like that I don't have time men
are not like that sometimes like so they
could be it's weird they do it in a
weird different way like they might tell
this guy like some other stuff about
some other information that's not true
because they like somebody else like
weird things like that or go he's just
salt in the player's game because he
wants this guy you know and he doesn't
realize that yet in their friends so
they might have a little battle going on
you know
um whereas women they're they're just
like oh just like [__] it's just like
miserable and just like what the [__]
like just get it like you know lighten
up dude come on you know like like I
always say look
I don't care
um I guess people think I'm attractive
right um I see like this I used to think
like this like I started I stopped
wearing bras just because they were
uncomfortable to me I go why the [__]
should I wear a bra because I don't I
don't like it you know and it was more
women who would shame me for that like
oh like you're a [__] you're you know
like oh look at her like sneering uh and
the way I saw was like this like the men
they'll stare at it and I I noticed that
it's cool though because as long as
they're not doing anything inappropriate
touching or like something I don't want
that's unwarranted I'm cool like because
I read one time that men just like uh
five minutes of looking at like tits or
something like maybe someone who's
stressed out makes them unstressed like
happy you know I go cool dude like if my
tits made you like less stressful like
smile like I'm all for it maybe even
made you want to [__] your wife more you
know like who gives a [__] like I'm cool
with it you know as long as it's like
you know like respectfully you know
um so it's just one of those things like
man most women aren't like that like
they're not just so like open about that
kind of stuff men get possessive and
women get catty yes and that's where
like to me I'm so glad that I was able
to let go of my possessiveness because I
didn't want to be a possessive person
like I I never ever would have wanted to
be in a healthy relationship with
somebody thinking like they're my
possession no never that like you know
it should be of your own free will that
you want to be with that person and like
like that person and be in that
relationship you know like not like
you're mine and only my like literally
like I'm not gonna expect my boyfriend
or my significant other or my partner
um to not look at somebody else and find
them attractive for example right like
I'm not gonna get jealous of that I'm
gonna be like cool dude like hell yeah
like well I like women too though you
know so I'm gonna be checking out women
too with them like or like you know guys
whatever the [__] like whatever we're
into you know I'm sure you've
encountered this where a lot of men will
get uh threatened by that
um sure you know what um I've had some
I've had some I was boyfriends before
and at first it's kind of cure endearing
you know like okay cute you know
for their taste no not necessarily I'll
tell you what I'm really not when I'm in
a committed relationship I'm devoted I'm
a very dedicated partner
um like I'm a really good girlfriend
um really
um and so it's one of those things like
literally like I don't see anybody else
I don't entertain anybody else you know
so it's just one of those things that I
might Garner attention and it's and it's
like not something that I'm trying to do
um literally like I've had this really
bad like experience in a sense with it
with like sexual assault and stuff um
it's an ugly thing people don't talk
people don't know about it I think it's
not it's maybe I'm gonna say it's a
fairly new phenomenon
um maybe with I don't know if it has
something to do with the tying of like
this repressed sexuality with men
because they might feel threatened
because they think like okay there's
this pretty girl
and I want that guy though and he's
interested in her and I'm just like I
don't really care though you can have
that guy I'm not trying to get his
attention though or I've had people who
have bisexual Partners who like me and
then they get jealous of their partner
liking me and I'm just like but I don't
even like your boyfriend though you know
like you you know I don't understand it
like what is it was the jealousy about
though you know
um they feel threatened and it's
unfortunate because I'm not doing it on
purpose you know like I can't help that
that maybe some people might find me
attractive you know like I wish they
didn't to be quite honest right like I'm
a very like a private kind of person
um I'm very shy too in reality like
right now I'm trying to become more
comfortable with like being more um
showing more skin because I'm very
reserved I'm a very reserved person so I
wanted to change that about myself I
wanted to be more like happy about my
body about my body image but it's such a
[__] like conflict sometimes with the
world and how the world works I guess
because you know if I'm too sexually
appealing then I'm at fault
and it's not like that it's like I just
want to feel pretty I want to feel
feminine
um I like you know people don't get that
they have feminine masculine energy it's
not about sexuality it's about energy
um
I'm a very dominant female I'm not like
an alpha female I would say
um so some people feel you know some
kind of a way about that but I don't
ever make it known immediately like I
just take whenever I have to take
control I take control but I'm a very
easy going person like laid back I don't
like I'm very like peaceful I would say
like a Peaceful Warrior I try to you
know emulate that as a maximum of like
how I should be in my life because I
don't ever want to get to a point where
like I'm violent or like I have to be
dominant in a situation but sometimes it
calls for it can you give an example of
what an alpha female behaves like
um I would say like I just really don't
care like I go for whatever I want
whenever I want and like No One's Gonna
Stand in my way like I would like to see
who would kind of thing like that's what
I think you'll initiate I'm just a [__]
I'm a [__] sucker and I'm like a [__]
caller too like I'll be like I'm gonna
call your bluff because I don't sit
around talking anyways I'm more of an
action kind of person so let's see what
it's at you know like that's just how I
am and so maybe because of that I get
along better with men because men are
really more action people they're more
action like they really are that's why
women depend on them well just like
there's all kinds of different females
there's all kinds of different men yeah
of course but I'll tell you what though
there's very few females like me
um that's why I can hang out with the
boys and like make jokes and like we're
not like so serious about that kind of
stuff like you're right I'll be raunchy
as [__] as a man like really like and
I'll be laughing with them we'd be
laughing and laughing and like other
women wouldn't do that with it they'd be
like oh my God or like oh how dare you
like I don't know what the hell you know
but like I'm telling like because I hang
out with guys more and it's just like I
almost feel like I'm one of the guys
um I'll be like we're we're at a poker
table it's mostly men but I'm that one
girl that they'll have over because like
we're joking and we're laughing having a
good time you know
um and I don't have to be [__] any of
them it's different you know and um
that's kind of like my power too I think
of where like I like that I don't have
sex with every single man even if they
find me attractive or we're flirting or
there's a flirtation interaction
um it's cool to just experienced that
that's what I mean that's normal and
that's natural like I wouldn't get
jealous if my boyfriend was interacting
with somebody like that where I would
get jealous is if like all of a sudden
now he's emotionally attaching himself
to her okay this is kind of worrisome
now you know like maybe you need to and
I wouldn't even be upset I would say
let's let's communicate about that if
you want to explore those uh feelings go
ahead like all the more reason for you
to do that because you feel that
strongly do it you know what I mean like
why would I be upset about that like yes
I'm hurt I'm sad but like as a bigger
person I want love for everybody you
know and I want the right love for me
too right like if that person is not
really committed to you emotionally let
them be with the person they want to be
if that's the case right you know so
that's a little difference where like
most women would feel like oh like a set
attached or like psychotic almost like
they won't leave the man alone or like
they're jealous or I don't even know
what you know it's just it's weird for
me at that point where I don't I don't
connect with them at that level you've
been in love before uh yeah I've been in
love you know I've uh had heartbreaks
um you know real love
um and I'm glad about that like I'm very
lucky and fortunate I would say you know
because some people go their whole lives
without real love like real real real
love where you want the best for that
person and you want to see that person
be the best version of themselves
and bring out that and Inspire them in
in different kinds of ways that maybe
they didn't even know about you know
like that's a beautiful thing and love
is a beautiful thing sexuality is a
beautiful thing it should be expressed
as such in a beautiful kind of manner
you know not in a nasty or like a
shameful or like dark or like secretive
kind of way like why why do you have to
feel like and some people like Secrets
though like I get it you know like maybe
that's their thing you know I don't know
you know like I'm into all kinds of
stuff that's the thing like I'm I'm just
like one of those like fetish people
like I'll be open about what I like you
know like I do I like like light B to
Sam like I I'm more of a dominant person
in my personality and like normal inter
personal relationships but
um sexually I'm more submissive you know
but I started experiencing more being
kind of like
um not submissive being more of the um
what do you call the more dominant
person right like and I remember the
first time that that experienced that
like because my partner used to like
always try to get girls for us to have
like because he you know I like girls so
he wanted to make me happy like like get
a girl for you like I don't even I don't
even want to figure I want to see you
guys [__] type [__] like and I'm like
cool like that's funny it's it's cute
it's endearing because he wants me to be
able to express my own sexuality as well
you know like or explore or have have it
as an option and I liked that I was like
that's such a like it's cute you know
and I would always laugh because I would
be like but I don't want to be with him
that I want to just be with you you know
and be laughing because they go you know
he's always trying so hard to get me
like a girl that I like or like try to
find out my type you know
um and then I would just be like you
know um one time there was a girl that
you know she was cool I liked her and we
would hang out with her and stuff I
don't know if you really if you maybe
she's a president you bought her I don't
even know you know I don't even care
though because it was cool we were
hanging out I'm not gonna like we were
smoking some crack here and there you
know
um and you know just having a good time
and I remember she was just telling me
like I want you to tell me like to get
on my knees and eat your [__] or like
you know like like order me around and I
just was like I can't like I was so shy
and I was just like what the [__] you
know but then I started thinking about
like what the [__] like I should be kind
of like I wanna I wanna you know explore
that you know so it's kind of cool and I
got to be able to like play a different
role that I wasn't used to like where I
like being more like manhandler like you
know like dominated
um I don't know I like it I explore I
like being dominant domination to me is
an interesting thing you know because
some people might not find power in it
but I do like I find it like you might
even think that you're like I always say
like look like I don't like and it's
always like I would say like it's all
the gay guys who put labels on stuff
though like you know like they label
different kinds of looks of how guys are
like bears are like you know this guy's
a dolphin or like whatever you know I go
I learned that [__] from you guys you
know and then I'm like what the [__] you
know it's like you guys do it to
yourself though you know like oh gosh
every
you know what you guys deserve each
other it's not like some guys are like
the best Partners sometimes they're not
you know like the guys are bad you know
they're bad bad bad sometimes and um you
know so it's love though um you know and
I I think it's a great thing um it's
cool
um I'm sorry I was getting at something
with this with the domination thing okay
that was that's what it was so I enjoy
anal sex
um not most women do I guess I don't
know if it's a common thing I don't know
what the [__] um but I do with the right
partner and I would say analysis about
communication okay because it's a
process and like when you do it though
it's a [__] orgasmic
um and I always say look even if I'm at
the bottom because it was a little
that's the [__] though like you're the
[__] and I'm going like what the [__]
is wrong with a [__] though like I
could still be at the bottom and I'm
writing your dick though you know like
come on dude like so it's funny to me
because I go like okay yeah sure I'm the
[__] but I'm the one that's riding your
dick you know like so it's kind of like
I'm On Top even though I'm on the bottom
though so it's like you can get your
power either way right and um that's
what I'm about it's like you should
Empower yourself if like you know
anything like don't make somebody feel
less than or like why you know like I'm
not into it so hey it's again different
jokes for different folks because some
people might really be into that though
I go like you know somebody May really
want to have a high heel smashed against
their face I don't know and they're into
that [__] I might be into that [__] you
know a little bit of humiliation you
know like hey it's sexy sometimes like
you know it sucks it should be fun it's
a play time that's what I think you know
I don't know people don't want to be
like that or something I don't I don't
know what's wrong with people man
um maybe I'm just a weirdo who the [__]
knows you know
all right Melina thank you so much for
sharing your thoughts on everything no
problem mainly yeah I'm telling you
that's like my favorite topic I love sex
it's healthy it's great it is thank you
very much you're welcome